[MUSIC PLAYING]
NADIM SAAD: Thank you,
Rob, and thank you
all for coming here
today and for taking
an hour of your busy schedules.
Reality is five years ago,
I would have never wasted
an hour of my time
attending a parenting
presentation because I parented
the way my parents did,
quite strict.
But I thought I turned
out OK, so why would
I do things differently.
Until one day an
event at home actually
made me really wonder if
I was doing things right.
So it was a Saturday.
My four and a half year
old daughter, Noor,
was serving herself some salad.
She dropped a salad
leaf on the table.
I just asked nicely, oh, Noor,
could you please pick this up.
She ignored me.
I said Noor, you dropped a
salad leaf, please pick it up.
She ignored me.
Then I used my default method
at the time, my technique
to get my children to do things
which was counting to three.
Anyone else count to three?
Show of hands?
Usually about 90% so
the rest are probably--
And I went OK, Noor,
I'm counting to three.
I said one.
Ignored me.
I said two.
Ignored me again.
I went, Noor, you don't want
me to get to three, do you?
Two and a half.
[LAUGHTER]
Two and three-quarters.
And then I got to three.
And the reality is I had no
idea what I was going to do.
The only thing I
knew was my authority
was based on that and the
fear of getting to three.
And it used to work so well
and suddenly it didn't.
Unfortunately I did not
react the best way possible.
I actually started
screaming and shouting.
And I pulled her up,
put her in her room.
Lecturing her, how dare
you let me get to three.
Do you realize what that means?
But I realized that day that
actually my whole authority
was based out of the fear
that my children had.
And they were doing
this out of fear
so I was really
managing my fear.
And that's what I'm going
to talk to you about today
and how much parallels there
are between leadership skills
and parenting skills.
So the outline for today
is actually explain to you
how I learned that parenting
skills can be improved.
Then I'm going to talk to
you about what parenting
and leadership have in common.
Then we're going to
actually work together
on defining what the key
leadership skills are.
And finally, I'll
show you how to apply
some of these workplace
skills at home.
So I'll share with you
five very effective tools
to replace the typical
basically, well, the one, two,
three, the parenting by fear or
parenting by rewards actually,
because it's the carrot
and stick approach.
My objective here
today is really
to give you alternatives
to the carrot
and stick approach that are
so ingrained in our culture.
Because it's all
about usually rewards,
punishment, threats, and
management basically by fear
or rewards.
So hopefully you'll leave here
with an alternative to that.
So how did it all start?
Well, I already explained,
I was a stricter parent.
And my wife was actually a
lot more, let's say, lenient.
I sometimes say permissive
although she doesn't like it.
And so that's how our daily
interactions look like.
And the problem is actually
the more, the harsher I was
and the kinder she was.
So I had, I had clearly
had the bad cop role,
she had the good cop role.
Anyone else experience
this at home?
Yeah, about 60%.
Well, actually it's-- the
research shows that it's 75%
of parents argue
about how to parent.
And more than 50%
of these arguments
are about how to
discipline children.
So that's what we
experience on a daily basis.
And it was, I mean it almost
got to break point, particularly
after the incident, the salad
leaf incident that I mentioned.
And thankfully, my wife
reacted very well to that.
And she actually started looking
for things she could do better.
So she stopped blaming me
for being the strict parent
and the harsher parent.
And she started looking
at ways she could improve.
And she actually
started proving to me
that she could get obedience
and respect without having
to shout and punish.
And that's finally, she had--
I was listening.
So instead of just
telling me oh,
here's this parenting
book you should read.
And I'd tell her oh, please
give me an exact summary
and show me how it works.
I don't have time for this.
Well, finally she
actually did it.
And she showed me
that-- so she became,
she actually set better limits.
She became more consistent.
And it really changed
the whole family dynamic.
And so I became interested
in and I became softer.
And so I started
looking at the research,
becoming interested
in the subject.
And I realized
how much parallels
there were between
leadership and parenting.
And actually that parenting
skills, like leadership skills
can be learned and can be honed.
And that's what I'm going
to talk to you about today.
So first, let's start
with leadership.
Obviously there are
so many definitions,
so I picked one that's
actually quite broad,
but I think really shows what
we want to do with our children.
It's from Dwight
Eisenhower and it says,
leadership is the art
of getting someone
else to do something
we want done
because they want to do it.
Isn't that what we
are trying to achieve
on a daily basis
with our children?
Wouldn't it be great if we
had tools to actually get
them to do things because
they want to do it,
not because we're telling
them over and over again,
you've got to do this.
Please do this, do that,
et cetera, giving them
orders all day long.
Well, so that's very
much, actually leadership
and parenting have
a lot of parallels.
And what they have
in common, I really
like this quote from Simon
Sinek, who you probably
know, author of
"Start With Why",
it's "Great leaders are able
to inspire people to act.
Those who are able to
inspire give people
a sense of purpose
or belonging that
has little to do with
any external incentive
or benefit to be gained."
If you replace the word
leaders with parents, here.
So great parents are able to
inspire the children to act.
Those who are able to
inspire give children
a sense of purpose of
belonging that has little
to do with any
external incentive
or benefit to be gained.
And this is really very
much, that's exactly what we
were saying about moving from
the carrot and stick approach
to the inspiring and
leading by example.
Another great quote from
Jack Welch, former CEO of GE
is "before you are
a leader, success
is all about growing yourself.
When you become
a leader, success
is all about growing others."
Again, if you replace the word
leaders with parents here,
is before you are
a parent, success
is all about growing yourself.
But when you become
a parent, success
is really about
growing your children.
So the last quotes
I'm going to show
you are about why leadership is
actually here, in this sense,
is different from management.
So because I spoke
about management by fear
and that's exactly, we want
to replace it with leadership.
And so management is about
arranging and telling,
while leadership is about
nurturing and enhancing.
And as Klaus Balkenhol,
Olympic champion
said, "there is a difference
between being a leader
and being a boss.
Both are based on authority.
A boss demands blind
obedience, while a leader
earns his authority through
understanding and trust."
So why don't we give a
go at actually defining
what the key leadership skills.
What have you experienced,
either as a manager--
and actually something that's
worked really well for you
in inspiring your teams.
Or if you've been
basically, you've
had managers and leaders who
have really inspired you,
what are the key
things that they've
done well that you remember?
AUDIENCE: Great communication.
NADIM SAAD: Great communication.
You can shoot, I can do several
things at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Being emphatic.
NADIM SAAD: Empathetic.
AUDIENCE: Having a plan.
NADIM SAAD: Sorry?
NADIM SAAD: Having a plan.
Right.
AUDIENCE: They show you.
So they're an example
of what they're asking.
NADIM SAAD: Can I call
this leading by example?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They listen.
NADIM SAAD: Listening,
empathy, empathetic listening.
Yeah, it's a different--
actually if you don't mind,
I'll later put this into
emotional intelligence.
Empathetic listening are
very much about being--
yes?
AUDIENCE: Stay
calm during crisis.
NADIM SAAD: Stay
Anything else that
comes to mind?
AUDIENCE: They know
when to delegate.
NADIM SAAD: Delegation.
So--
AUDIENCE: They're inspirational.
NADIM SAAD: Inspirational.
AUDIENCE: Having a
purpose or vision.
NADIM SAAD: Vision and purpose.
AUDIENCE: Have fun.
NADIM SAAD: Sorry,
I didn't hear that.
AUDIENCE: Have fun.
NADIM SAAD: Have, fun, OK.
OK, fun, can I also say
positive attitude in there?
AUDIENCE: They serve
as your advocate.
NADIM SAAD: Sorry, I
have space for two more.
AUDIENCE: They serve
as your advocate.
NADIM SAAD: They're--
AUDIENCE: Serves as an advocate.
NADIM SAAD: Serve?
AUDIENCE: As an advocate.
NADIM SAAD: Advocate, they--
sorry.
AUDIENCE: They advocate
for their team.
NADIM SAAD: They advocate
for their team, yeah.
AUDIENCE: A safe place to fail.
NADIM SAAD: And I heard
safe place to fail.
Yes, very good.
AUDIENCE: And also
that [INAUDIBLE].
NADIM SAAD: Well,
I absolutely love
doing this exercise every time.
This is a great list.
And you'll see, no surprise,
I'll have my list at the end.
It's the same.
So thank you very much.
And actually I'm going to
hopefully show you five tools,
well, not hopefully.
I'm going to show you five tools
that use all of these skills
and how to find them at home.
So the first one
is about strategy
and anticipating issues.
I'd like to share
with you a story of,
so we had just moved home.
I had a six-year-old and a
four-year-old at that time.
And they were
arriving half an hour
late for breakfast,
which meant no breakfast.
We didn't have time so we
had to just rush to school.
So I sat them with, sat
down with them on Sunday.
And I asked my
six-year-old, Noor,
how long do you need to
get dressed in the morning?
She answered, two minutes.
I said, OK, so you're actually
currently taking half an hour
for something you could
do in two minutes.
OK, so what can
you do differently?
And she actually
came up with the idea
that why don't we
write down timings
so that we actually know what
time we should be going down.
I said that's a great idea.
Let's do it.
It was actually a two hour,
in the end, a two hour
activity where the kids,
I took photos of the kids
as they were doing the
different activities.
So making their bed,
brushing their teeth,
their hair, getting dressed.
And then we put it in order.
They actually ordered
the way they wanted.
And we put timings, they didn't
really have a sense of time,
particularly
four-year-old at the time.
But I helped them with that.
Turned out actually to
be one of the best things
we've ever done.
Because the next day, they
arrived half an hour earlier
than usual.
We had lots of time to have
breakfast and have lots of fun.
Anyone actually
already uses routines?
Creates a routine?
Yeah.
Yeah, kind of.
About 20% to 25%.
Do you involve your children in
doing in creating this routine?
Yeah.
Quite, some yes, some no.
Well, it's very much, it
is very much valuable.
And so the idea of
creating routines
is really steps and schedule
to make them the boss.
So with younger
children as I just used,
you can have photos of
these different steps
and I'll ask them to
reorder them as they want.
With older children, agree
on a schedule with them.
What's important about this is
really about using this as--
so the routine becomes
the boss as in,
what are you supposed to
do now, instead of oh,
you still didn't
brush your teeth.
What have you put
in your schedule?
in your routine?
And automatically it gives
an ownership and empowerment
to the children to
want to do things.
And so it removes a
lot of the resistance
that we experience
in the morning.
The other one about
being strategic
is redesign agreement's
is realizing
where are our key issues.
And often, it's going
to be a supermarket
or when we go to a
friend's house, you know.
And it's all about
agreeing with your children
what's OK with you, so
clarifying expectations
at any age.
So for younger
children, for example,
you can use what we
call an "I" message.
I take children
to the supermarket
who will listen to me, who will
not be trying to buy everything
on the shelf or take it
or touching everything
on the shelves and et
cetera, what works for you.
And ideally you involve them.
So you say for
example, you will help
me put things that are on your
list, list of your things.
So there are usually actually
very good supermarkets
in doing this and putting
them at the right height.
And also for example,
I'm willing to buy
you one thing under two, three
pounds, whatever works for you.
Just having this expectation,
having clarified this,
and if you want role play.
Role play is great
for example for when
you go to your friend's house.
And you instead of going
oh, say hello, say goodbye,
say thank you.
I mean how often do we repeat
these things to our children?
Well, the reality is instead
if we role play and ask them
so granny is going to say hello,
what are you going to say?
Oh, hello.
OK, she's going to give
you a piece of cake.
What do you need to do?
Oh, I'll say thank you.
Just going through that with
them, when I'm talking here
about younger children,
will enable them to get it
in their long term memory.
And you'll be a lot surer that
they actually do this regularly
rather than you having to
repeat it to them all the time.
So that's about
being more strategic.
Effective communication,
obviously great communication
is so important.
And reality is often it's
not all about what we say
but how we say it.
So can you try
and guess how many
orders and commands a child
gets every hour on average?
Is it 5 to 10, 10 to
20, 20 to 30, 30 to 40?
Any guesses?
AUIDENCE: I would say 20.
AUDIENCE: 30 to 40.
NADIM SAAD: 30 to 40.
40.
Wow, first time I guessed
the exact-- it's actually 34.
Very good.
So it's 34 orders.
How would it go down with
you if you're actually,
your boss gave you
34 orders every hour?
Yeah, you can imagine.
So it actually
explains very well
the resistance they have
from the age of two, three.
I mean they've received so many
orders through their childhood
and so many no's that is
pretty normal for them
to react like this.
So what are the alternatives?
What is great communication
with children?
It is actually trying to replace
at least 90% of these orders
with first [INAUDIBLE]
of all questions.
So think about actually
is this new information.
So every time you say
something to your child,
it's like is this
new information?
Do you think that 90%, about 90%
will probably be new, you know,
old information?
And so instead of repeating
yourself, ask them,
what are you--
so the same with creative
[INAUDIBLE], you know,
what are you supposed to do now?
What do we do when we
come out, you know,
when before we leave after
we come back from whatever
your rules are, they know them.
So put them in thinking
mode a lot more
and they'll actually be
a lot less resistant.
Question works also very well
when they make a mistake.
What are you going to do now?
Because usually we tell
them or take them out.
For example, they
spill something.
Take them up, do this, do that,
because we're quite annoyed.
Well actually, giving
them the opportunity
to correct their mistake
and have a safe place
to fail, you know, is essential.
And so that's what is
really replacing our orders
with so asking questions.
The other one, which is also
questions is limited choices.
Anyone uses limited choices?
So it's not like, oh, what
do you want for breakfast
this morning?
And then you never
get an answer.
Or you reflect because
it creates anxiety.
It's actually much
better to say would you
like porridge or cereals?
Would you like juice or milk?
So all limited choices
actually keep our children
in thinking mode and removes
a lot of the resistance
that we experience.
And I'm talking at any age.
You know, we just think
oh, they're old enough.
Come on why am I going
to give them choices?
Well actually, 10-year-olds,
12-year-olds, they
prefer choices to hey,
you didn't do that
or you forgot to do this.
The other way about
effective communication
is actually reducing
the use of no.
No is actually one of the most
dangerous words in the world.
Research shows that it
reduces the motivation.
It affects us
actually physically.
And it's a word that
we repeat so often.
Often actually we start
our sentences with no
when we want to say yes.
So I challenge you to try and
start most of your sentences
with yes, at home and
at work by the way.
And it's yes, and if it
doesn't work for you, it's yes
and we can do this later.
For example, I
want an ice cream.
Yes, sure, you can
have it at the weekend.
That's our rule at home.
Yes, yes, yes, but redirect.
You'll see the difference.
Instead of going
OK, no, I want one.
They'll go, oh, OK.
Or ask a question.
Is it time to have an ice cream?
So really it's
the same tools you
use at work to
motivate your teams
or actually have a
good relationship
with your colleagues.
I challenge you to do
more of this at home.
Other big theme,
leading by example.
And instead of do as I say
and not as I do, you know,
do as I say and as I do.
And as I was doing research,
I realized the huge defining
moments for me.
I realized that I was making
it harder for my children to do
what I was asking from them.
I would often say, stop crying.
Calm down.
Anyone else?
Stop crying.
Calm down.
Pretty common.
Well actually what the research
shows is that when we do this,
they are probably already in
what we call fight or flight
mode.
They're already in a state
where they're really finding
it hard to get out of it.
When we raise our voices and
we say stop crying, calm down,
actually it increases the level
of cortisol in their body.
Instead of coming back to
their prefrontal cortex,
this logical part of the brain
where we want them to be.
They're actually in
their primitive brain,
where we also called the chimp
in some management books.
And so if we actually--
I realized that I
was making it harder
for them to do these things.
While what we should
do is actually
anticipate a lot of
issues as we saw earlier
and help them get out.
You know, replace the cortisol
with oxytocin, with dopamine.
So the right
hormones to actually
be wanting to do things.
And so I actually had a big
experience when Noor was five
and she spoke to me for the
first time in an incredibly
disrespectful voice.
And I just was going to
just fly off the wall,
I mean I was so angry.
But I realize that we
were both in our chimp,
in our primitive brain.
So I used what I call ABC.
So A for acknowledge my
feelings, I'm very angry.
B for breathe.
And C for choice.
And actually I made the
choice to remove myself
from the situation rather
than lecture her and scold
her right there and then.
And as I gave myself
some time I realized
that she spoke in
exactly the same way
as I had been doing
for the last few years.
And the problem is actually
they've got deferred memory.
So it only came out at five.
So for the ones who have
younger children, hopefully
you can still correct things
so that you don't end up
having children actually
speak to you in exactly
the same way you speak to them.
And obviously it's
not respectful,
you can't speak to
another like this.
But ideally we should
be leading by example.
And obviously that applies,
it's easy to apply this
to stricter parents and
parents who get angry.
But I also want
to share with you
a story of a couple who
seemed like the absolutely
most amazing perfect parents.
And they had a
daughter called Lisa.
And they simply adored
her and they decided
to give her unconditional love.
So as she was brought up, they'd
take her everywhere with them.
Until the age of
two, they didn't even
take a night out together.
And so when she turned two, they
decided to book a babysitter.
And they told Lisa, oh,
we booked a babysitter.
We really wanted this night out.
She threw a tantrum.
They canceled the babysitter.
Then Lisa turned out
to be this lovely girl.
She grew up to--
always very generous
like giving her lunch whenever
someone else didn't have lunch,
always being responsible
for brownies at parties.
But unfortunately
when she turned 14,
she became angry,
resentful and her parents
could not understand.
And so they kept telling her
but we sacrificed everything
for you, how can you
treat us like this.
So they went to see a
psychiatrist, friend of theirs.
They told the story.
And he said, well unfortunately
you trained her that way.
What do you mean?
We did everything,
we've been so nice and--
what do you mean we
train her that way?
He told them well, unfortunately
actions speak louder
than words.
And what you've
modeled is actually
that your needs were
not so important.
And her needs-- you didn't
model how to say no.
You didn't actually develop her
frustration and disappointment
muscle.
So what's happening to her is
simply that she cannot cope.
She does not have the
coping mechanism of emotions
to manage her emotions.
And so that was a
huge realization
for my wife, who actually
tended to be more like this.
And so you can see that from
both sides of the spectrum.
So leading by example
is really about actions
that speak louder than words.
So how could you implement
this on a daily basis?
For example, if you want
your children to be grateful,
you can actually show gratitude.
If you want them to be--
so for example, if you want
them to know how to fail
and how to accept mistakes,
you can share your mistakes.
We do that during
our dinners when we
manage to have dinner together.
We share the mistakes we made
and what we learned from them.
Because we realized that
our children were starting
to be perfectionists, which is
actually very common nowadays.
So you can implement, you
can really lead by example
and bring these things
into your daily lives.
So hopefully you won't have,
you will have good followers.
So I want to
actually ask you, I'm
sure that you have
regular meetings,
interim meetings at work.
Surely that's quite
regular and common.
So what are actually
the goals and objectives
of these meetings?
Or why do you have
internal meetings?
Can you give me ideas?
AUDIENCE: We talk
through what's happening.
NADIM SAAD: So talk through.
So basically you're discussing--
AUDIENCE: Like the agenda.
NADIM SAAD: Yeah, agenda.
Sure.
So we're basically, we're
kind of planning, [INAUDIBLE]
for a weekend planning.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] .
NADIM SAAD: Assess performance.
Does that actually
happen on a weekly basis?
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: To reach agreements.
NADIM SAAD: Reach agreements.
So negotiate?
Yeah, so negotiate.
Would it be solve solutions and
negotiate to agree on solutions
to problems or just negotiate?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Highlight problems.
NADIM SAAD: Highlight problems.
AUDIENCE: Praise
and recognition.
NADIM SAAD: Praise
Yes, so can I add to this that
it would be motivating maybe
as well?
So you get the motivation to--
get recognition to motivate.
AUDIENCE: Setting expectations.
NADIM SAAD: Set expectations.
OK.
I'll-- one last one.
AUDIENCE: Strengthen
relationships.
NADIM SAAD: Strengthen
relationship, yeah, bonding,
strengthen relationships.
Great, and I like that
we finished on that.
Because when you
see this list, can
you see how it would be useful
to have this at home as well.
Bonding, set expectations,
praise and recognition,
highlight problems,
and address them,
obviously problem
solving, reach agreements.
So now I have a
question for you is
how many of you
have regular family
meetings on a weekly basis?
Great question.
Meals do not count.
It's usually 5%.
Come on, tell me someone
has a regular meeting.
Once a week?
No.
OK, well this is really the
most important tool in the book.
So thanks for being honest.
And family meetings are
actually run very much
like a business meeting.
They've got-- and
for doing it once
a week because
what you don't want
is actually for
children to think
that you're only doing them
when there's a big problem.
Because otherwise they
become reluctant to do them
while the idea is to
have a real motivation
to do them because it is
a real bonding experience.
So elect a chairperson
and a secretary.
The reason for this is because
if you don't, then they
can go completely--
you need someone to manage.
But the secretary
is really important,
and actually children
from the age of five,
six, love to take the
secretary and actually
just write the minutes down.
And agenda, of course,
we need agenda.
And actually on the
agenda, we start
with compliments and gratitude.
So for example, our
five-year-old daughters
told our three-year-old
daughter at some point, Yasmin,
thank you for biting
me less this week.
And that actually came from
a previous family meeting
the week before where
we gave Yasmin ideas
on how she could bite less.
So it had worked quite well.
What each family member is proud
of, that's actually something
that at seven, our daughter
said oh, can I talk to myself.
I'm grateful for
actually having finished
"Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory"
and reading so much better.
We said, oh, so
you're proud of this.
Yeah, sure, of course you
can be proud of yourself.
And actually it's a
great moment to show
what we're proud of as adults
and to lead by example.
And for our children
to know how to focus on
the positives and not
just the negatives.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Personal related
like as in only family related?
Or would you talk
about work [INAUDIBLE]?
NADIM SAAD: So it is
only, so the question
is about whether it's
work or family related.
It's actually family related.
There's already so much to
talk about on a weekly basis
or even if you do it
bi-weekly, it's really,
it's really effective.
It completely changes
the family dynamic.
So the next step,
which is really the one
that every parent
wants to get to
is the needs, problem solving.
Let's actually address
all the issues we have.
So the way we did
it, so it was--
so the girls already had an idea
of what a family meeting was.
And that day we asked them
what their needs were.
So that's what's so
important is actually
for children to feel that they
also have their needs met.
They'll start
probably with oh, I
want to go to Disneyland
Paris and they
want to do this and that.
We tell them oh,
sure, we'll put this
on the agenda for the future.
But right now do
you have any needs?
So my four-year-old
daughter said daddy, I'd
like you to shout less.
I was going to go, but I'm
really shouting so much less.
Don't you see the
efforts I'm making.
I mean you should--
come on.
And then I was going to
go, well you make me shout.
I stopped myself in my
tracks and I said, oh, you
want me to shout less.
Well, I'd love to
do that actually
and I promise I'm going to
make a conscious effort.
But so why don't we
actually as a family
think about what we could
do to have less screaming
or generally because there
is quite a bit of shouting
in the family.
So we brainstorm and actually
realize that a lot of shouting
happened in the morning.
Because, you know, this great
routine that we created.
The problem is now
they had half an hour
to have all the time to--
for breakfast and fun.
Well, we still ended up
being late for school
because then by the
time we told them OK,
now it's time to get ready,
to get-- finalize the dressing
so we can get out the door.
It take 15 minutes instead of
the 2 or 3 that it should take.
So we brainstorm ideas.
And actually I said
you could actually
wake up earlier so you'd
have to go to sleep earlier.
They said no, no
that doesn't work
because we wouldn't see then.
You come back late from work.
So no, no.
Let's try something else.
So they actually came
up with a simple idea,
just remind us by singing.
So unfortunately I had
to sing, "Let us go.
Let us go."
it was a big "Frozen" mania.
And so I said, really you want
me to do this, I hate singing.
OK.
OK, I'll do that.
Next morning, I
went, "Let us go.
Let us go."
They put their skates on,
they were like two minutes.
They were ready at the door.
I was like, wow, that
looks like magic.
Well the reality is it's
because they found the solution,
because they agreed on this.
Whether, I mean we also
use now, thankfully they
don't ask me to sing too much.
But they asked me for
example to use respect.
So if-- or rewind.
So if they've done
something that they're not
supposed to do, instead of
immediately lecture them.
They have an opportunity
by saying rewind.
For example, they have an
opportunity to do it better.
And this is the
amazing way for them
to acknowledge their
mistake and to actually
practice doing things better.
So and that all came out of our
family meetings and our problem
solving sessions.
So in summary, the way to
do a problem solving session
is you say, what
can we do about it.
Then you generate possible
alternate solution together.
Ideally you find more than one
solution so they can really,
you can get buy in.
You know how at work,
if just someone comes up
with a solution and
you just get on,
you just think I'm sure
there was a better idea.
And so ideally you find
two or three solutions
and all agree on
what the best one is.
And after each option you
should ask, how would that
work for you to really
empower your children
to choose the best option.
So you will decide together on
the best acceptable solution.
And finally, we ask them how
would you like to be reminded.
So in they're-- in this case,
they wanted to be reminded with
the singing or with a word
like respect or rewind.
And then finally, I would
suggest particularly
with older children to ask them
what the consequence would be
if they don't end up complying.
You know, you do tell them.
Look, I totally trust that
we've done this together
and you've agreed so
you're going to do it.
But sometimes, you know, we
slip in life, it happens.
And so if you agree on a
consequence, and in this case,
actually the agreement was
in the case of what I--
the story I just told
you, was that they
would have to go to sleep
earlier and wake up earlier.
So it wasn't, it's
not a punishment,
it's not a-- it's just a simple
natural logical consequence
of their actions.
And the more you
do this, the more
they actually start realizing
that it's not about punishment.
And it's just that in life, you
just have normal consequences
to your actions.
And so that's a great
way to achieve this.
So how do you create
a shared purpose?
Actually is the final
point is you also
either do a problem
solving session
or you do what we call I
mean you try and instill
a family culture.
The reality is company
culture happens
whether we want it to or not.
And actually as
you know we spend,
I mean the company spends
so much money on making sure
that the culture
is communicated,
that we all are aware of it.
Well, in our family lives,
unfortunately often we
don't realize that we are
creating a culture whether we
want it or not.
So my intention
here is just to make
you realize that by becoming
more intentional about it,
it's much better.
So how we define
a family culture,
it's the unique way that
a family forms itself
in terms of rules, roles,
habits, activities, beliefs,
and other areas.
And you can imagine that these
things just happen naturally.
So actually when we become
more intentional about them,
it enables us to decide what
we want to be as a family.
Have more vision and strategy.
So fun, sporty, kind, curious,
what are the values we
want to give to our children.
You know, care of
self, care for others.
Effort is good.
Whatever works for you,
every family is different.
But just becoming more conscious
and strategic about this
can make a huge difference to
your children as they grow.
And so ask yourself, what
actions can lead to this?
Agree during a family meeting
that OK, let's do more of this
because we want to be
like this as a family.
And try actually if you
have all the children.
Ask them, what do you
think our values are?
Do kind of what we
call a two minute quiz.
So OK, tell us in three,
four words what you
feel that we are as a family.
And you'd be surprised sometimes
at the answers they give,
they can give you.
And so ideally you
actually, if you're not
happy with the answers
then you get an opportunity
to discuss these and make
sure that you correct things
before it's too late.
So overall, you want to
finish on a positive note.
Because it's like sandwich
or like feedback, sorry,
you want to do it as a sandwich.
Positive, so compliments
and gratitude.
Then you put the problem
solving, the part where you
know, hey, we've got problems.
Let's solve them.
But you want to finish
on a positive note.
So after problem solving
and family culture,
we plan activities
and family fun.
You know, what we usually
do in work meetings as well.
Play a family game
if you've got time.
Because obviously these
things, sometimes you
skip the problem solving
because we don't have problems.
We just use the family
meeting as a bonding session.
So we have time
for a family game.
And it's a bit cheesy, but we
always finish with a family hug
and the children love it.
So overall, I wanted
to check with you.
What leadership
skills do you feel
that we've used actually
coming back to everything
you've defined?
Well, I mean, I promised
I would show you my list.
Well, here it is.
Vision and strategy.
So family culture,
anticipating issues,
it's very much about
vision and strategy.
Leading by example, I think I
went through that in detail.
Effective
communication, you know,
the replacement of
all the negative,
the negatives, the orders with
more motivating techniques.
Collaborative as
well as directive.
You know, it's very
important to actually
when you do a family
meeting, you're
asking them to also
collaborate to find solutions
to their problems,
to empower them.
Emotional intelligence,
ability to listen,
to be empathetic
with our children.
Motivating and inspiring.
Valuing mistakes as
opportunities for learning.
As we said, you know,
teaching them to fail and lead
by example.
Positive attitude and
flexibility pragmatism.
Trust and integrity.
And finally, something we
couldn't be parents without
is determination and commitment.
And I want to acknowledge
you all as parents
because we have a tough job.
And so hopefully the
session has given you
a bit more ideas on how to
address these challenging times
and really find solutions.
And realize that
actually it is all
about being a leader at home as
we want to be leaders at work.
And by applying
these techniques,
we can really make
our family lives
easier and more harmonious.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Right,
thank you, Nadim.
It's quarter past 1:00, and
so we have about 10 minutes
for questions or so.
And please use the mic
to ask the question.
Any questions from the floor?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was just
wondering about ages where
you can start some of this.
Because I've got
young children so
I totally see the benefit of
what you're talking about.
But I also think they are
not going to get it yet.
So when--
NADIM SAAD: Can I ask how
old your children are?
AUDIENCE: Two and zero.
[LAUGHTER]
NADIM SAAD: Well,
congratulations on the--
two actually is a
great age to start,
particularly limited
choices, asking questions.
Making sure, basically you want
to remove the resistance that
comes with--
I don't know if you're,
I mean autonomy,
there is this need
for autonomy identity
that comes in human beings.
And it comes in peaks.
It comes at two, that's what
explains the terrible twos.
It comes back at 12, which is
adolescence and older people.
It comes back at 40.
It explains a lot of
the midlife crisis.
And then again at 80.
So two is really a great
moment to start and apply
a lot of basically
remove the resistance.
Creating routines, you
know, everything basically
a lot of the-- leading by
example can start at any age.
I hope you can use
some, I mean we
have talks that is more
specific for younger children.
But I hope that some
of the ideas here,
you can definitely commend.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
The kind of frustration I
guess that I have with my kids
is that, and this
could go on by the way.
The frustration, I think is
that the ability for me to
or the inability of me
to articulate kind of
do the boring stuff to
get to the fun stuff.
So that brushing
teeth, and I get
what you're saying
about routine,
but I guess I have
trouble articulating.
Like it'll take you two
minutes to brush your teeth.
And then you get 20
minutes to mess about.
And the whole process to get
them from start to finish
will take 25 minutes.
You know what I mean.
NADIM SAAD: I totally, totally--
AUDIENCE: I need help
articulating that to them.
Please, please help.
NADIM SAAD: Yes.
And I agree.
I still get frustrated at this.
Because actually it's
understanding what is age
appropriate is the hardest--
was the hardest bit for me.
Realizing that actually
the prefrontal cortex,
so this logical
part of the brain,
understanding what the
consequences of our actions,
that takes until the age of 25.
That's actually when we
become really adults,
when our prefrontal
cortex stops growing.
Until then, unfortunately
they don't have hindsight.
They don't realize
that oh, of course,
I mean unless we do it
outside of the actions, which
is why the whole idea of
routines, of problem solving,
is doing when
they're not already
in this kind of
resistance and outside
of the prefrontal cortex.
And so these tools
to remind them
that we agree that
it's much better.
Because outside, so you do
a problem solving session,
you say, would you prefer
to dress for 25 minutes
and then have 2 minutes to play?
Or do you have to
dress for 2 minutes
and actually play for 25?
They'll go, play
25, dress 2 minutes.
Great.
OK.
And that's where
you're going to say,
OK, well we have
agreement on that.
What can I do to remind you
that this is what you want?
They'll give you an idea and
I promise, try it at home,
you will--
I mean it's not going to
work 100% of the time.
But it's going to work,
particularly at the beginning
if you're consistent
about it, because they--
you empowered them to
decide for themselves
and you reminded them
in a nice fun way.
So it unfortunately
takes more effort.
But unfortunately
that's what our children
have to go through.
We're here to coach
them to really develop
this prefrontal cortex.
Because what we want is for them
to reach adolescence and not
make huge mistakes.
And mistakes suffer
from inflation.
So the younger they make
mistakes, the better.
Because when they're
14, 15, and they
go into a car with someone
who's drunk et cetera,
you want them to
anticipate, to realize
the consequences of this.
And so the more we
actually teach them
the consequences of
their actions early on,
the better-- well, the more
their prefrontal cortex
is going to be developed
and the better they're
going to react to this.
So it takes more time,
but it's so worth it.
Because then you get
into this really,
you have this shared purpose
and this sense of motivation
to want to do things because
they want to do them,
not because we're after them.
And because you could,
you could be playing.
Come on.
Very frustrating, but.
AUDIENCE: I have a
lovely adorable daughter.
Well, until she turned 19
months and she realized
she can have an opinion.
We are struggling,
me and my wife,
to figure out how do
we negotiate with her.
She's 19 months,
she can't understand
what we want to tell her.
But she realized she
can have an opinion.
She can wake up and say,
I'm not going to sleep.
We don't just let her
cry herself to sleep.
But we want to, find out a
way of negotiating with her.
She will say she will not
have breakfast this morning.
She doesn't like the milk
is too cold, it's too old.
So it's--
NADIM SAAD: Thanks
for the question.
It is very much, if I may,
I think the word negotiation
is in itself--
I mean, ideally you move
away from negotiating
with your children.
Because otherwise
everything turns out
and turns into a negotiation.
So what we want is
actually for them
to have a sense of control.
That's crucial.
That's so for them
not to be a two
and just be resistant and
not want to do anything.
But so giving them
limited choices.
So for example, do you
want your milk cold or hot?
So you're anticipating the
issue before she tells you oh, I
want my milk hot actually.
So you allow her
to make decisions
based on limited choices,
that will be usually helpful.
But you do not negotiate.
And then if it's actually she
decided she wanted it cold.
And she then goes no,
actually I want it hot.
Just like oh, next time Darling.
Today you decided cold.
Because otherwise
it's her way for--
it's her way to control you.
Because they do have
this need for control.
So don't get me wrong,
it's totally normal.
It's age appropriate.
But you want to teach
them that they can have
control, but on your terms.
Otherwise they're
running the show.
And then you've got a really
difficult life because it all
turns out into a negotiation.
So limited choices,
asking questions,
and enforceable
statements, which
is another one I
didn't really mention.
For example, children in this
house who want to have dessert
must have eaten their
meal, for example.
So instead of, if
you don't do this,
you won't get that,
which is very threatening
and it really
creates opposition.
You try and create
more positive ways.
So as soon as you've done
that, you can do this.
So it doesn't put the
child in resistance mode.
I hope that helps.
AUDIENCE: Next to being,
like giving them control,
do you have some
suggestions on how
to let them break rules
and be [INAUDIBLE]?
Because I mean that's why they
are wired to a certain age
to them and try to
break the rules.
How would you
suggest to do that?
NADIM SAAD: So the question
is how often should you
let them break the rules?
Or should you let them
break the rules at all?
I mean what's was the question?
AUDIENCE: So the question
stems from the fact
that they are wired to break
the rule at some point.
And feeling that giving them
too much of this management
leadership style might then
transform them into anarchists,
they just want to avoid all of
that when they are teenagers.
So how do you allow for an
element of breaking the rules?
NADIM SAAD: OK, so it's--
well, that's a tough
one because my wife
and I would answer differently.
Because she would
allow more exceptions.
Because of my parenting style,
I allow less exceptions.
And I think that's what
we're talking about here.
My view of life is actually
there are rules everywhere
and actually my
children have to teach--
have to learn that early on.
So I wouldn't allow for
a lot of breaking rules.
To make up for
that, they are not
allowed to break up many rules,
there are some exceptions.
So I say, OK, you know what,
I'll make an exception.
Go ahead, for example,
break a rule that is not,
you know, is not
so important for me
or so choose your battles.
It's fine.
But the rest of the time, I make
it clear that that's the rule.
But to make up
for that rigidity,
you actually create a
lot of autonomy within--
you offer a lot of choices.
You anticipate a lot of issues
by actually having covered it,
by being collaborative.
So they feel they have a
say and they are empowered.
And they feel they've got a
shared purpose and belonging.
As long as you have
this, you'd be surprised
that children actually are a
lot less intent on breaking
the rules just to break them.
They break them
because they just feel,
they're like oh my god,
there are so many rules.
I can't bear all this.
So as long as you give
enough control and autonomy,
children will actually learn
to make mistakes and it's fine,
but there are
consequences to this.
So they learn that there are
consequences for mistakes.
It's not big punishment
and oh, horrible.
It's actually, the idea is not
to make children feel worse
in order to do better.
It's for them to
always feel good
and to want to be in this family
and want to do things correctly
because they see that
otherwise, you know,
my parents are not
going to be happy.
Or it's not actually counter to
the way the family functions.
So hopefully it's
that, you know,
it's for you to decide
how many exceptions you're
going to make.
But if you make too
many, then you're
letting them run
the show and not
realize there is a
consequence and that there
are rules while you want
to teach them the rules.
AUDIENCE: So sometimes breaking
rules or at least perceived
rules can be a good thing.
Are you concerned or
is there any evidence
to show or counter
evidence that you're
going to end up
raising a child who
isn't capable of breaking rules
when we see rules as an adult?
Because I want my son to be
able to break rules sometimes.
NADIM SAAD: Totally,
again, it's--
I mean, it's a similar
question and I understand that.
And it's funny because I rarely
get these kind of questions.
And clearly Google
is very much, it
is part of the Google culture.
And I think that's great.
I think it's, you
know, you want to be--
to question, you know, the
rules and then otherwise you
can't actually create a lot.
I think it's about
finding this right balance
as I was explaining.
But really it's offering
a lot of autonomy
and a lot of opportunities
to do things differently
and to decide what
the rules are.
So for example, in the
problem solving session,
you're not imposing your
rule on your children.
You're telling them,
OK, that's what we
want as an outcome as a family.
So what are the right rules
for our family to achieve this?
And sometimes you'll
go against your feeling
like, oh my god, really?
But you'll go with it.
And you'll just
go, you know, OK.
I mean, I don't really
agree but I'll go with that.
That in itself is
kind of a way to teach
them to think differently,
to think outside of the box,
and to find solutions
to problems.
I think that's what
we want to achieve.
Just breaking the
rules for the sake
of breaking them is kind of
goes, it will go against you.
And sometimes, and
it's fine, they
have to make
mistakes by the way.
So it's not like
that we're going
to create these perfect kids
who never break the rules.
It's just when they
break them, instead
of getting angry and
thinking, oh my god how
dare you do that, it's
actually oh, so sad.
You know what the rules are.
So that's a mistake.
It's OK and that's the
consequence that you agreed on.
And then instead of going
no, that's not fair.
They'll go, yeah, I mean I
decided this consequence.
It's fine.
You know, and it's tough.
It can be tough, but it's fine.
I hope that answers.
AUDIENCE: Right,
thanks for the talk.
My kids are 8 and 12 and
we have some routines
that work quite well for us.
But then we have some which have
been really non established,
and which we would like
to change because they
don't necessarily work out now.
So for example, we
used to always get
into do some kind of
practice after dinner.
But we find these days that
perhaps everybody's a bit tired
then and piano practice can
get a bit confrontational.
And we'd like to bring it
earlier in the day maybe
before dinner and say then
we're met with big resistance.
I wonder if you have tips on
how to kind of deal with that.
NADIM SAAD: So is there
resistance because they just
want to have fun
before and that they
are used to doing it after
or where does it come from?
AUDIENCE: Because in
their mind, piano practice
is always after dinner
NADIM SAAD: OK, so there's--
AUDIENCE: At least
that's what's voiced.
I mean maybe there's
something else.
But yeah, that's the
objection that we're given.
NADIM SAAD: Yeah,
well this is very--
usually that's very much the
purpose of a family meeting.
Is when it's outside of this
kind of resistance already,
you should do it before.
But you can agree on
why it's better for them
to do it earlier.
I mean that's where usually,
when you get-- you get buy in.
It's like any meeting.
To get buy in, they mustn't
be in resistant mode.
They have to realize
what the intention is
and why it's better.
And or otherwise you say
well, the consequence
could be well you have
to have dinner earlier
and maybe then we can't
participate in dinner.
I mean things-- you can actually
make things up so that to make
sure that--
I mean it's not, it's
just showing them
the consequence of
not going that way
without it being a battle.
Because that's what you want
to remove and everything we do
is remove those.
This battle, these positions,
that it's a win-lose situation.
Actually everything is
a win-win situation.
I mean we're doing
this for our kids.
So they have to realize it.
And the more you create this
environment of shared purpose
and we have the
same goals, the more
you can achieve no
resistance to piano practice.
Actually yeah, it's true
actually, I'm going to do it.
Invent, I mean do it, be
creative, that's what I mean.
And they're going to be your
best creative, you know,
they're going to bring
the best creative ideas.
So allow them to have these
ideas because maybe they'll
come up with something
that works for you,
and that you didn't
even think about.
So to have these conversations.
SPEAKER 2: All
right, and with that
please join me in a
massive round of applause
for Nadim Saad.
[APPLAUSE]